كشريكا اساسيه تدخل شركه قطر للطاقه مجاله
تنقيب عن النفط والغاز في المياه
اللبنانيه ضمن تحالف مع شركتين فرنسيه
وايطاليه وحلت قطر للطاقه مكانه نوفاتيك
الروسيه التي كانت انسحبت من التحالف في
اغسطس الماضي وعليه جرى تعديل الاتفاقيه
بين الحكومه اللبنانيه والتحالف لتنقيب في
الركعتين اربعه وتسعه ضمن المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه للبنان ان هذه
الاتفاقيه المهمه تمنحنا فرصه لدعم
التنميه الاقتصاديه في لبنان خلال هذا
المنعطف الحرج وورده هنا ان يؤكد لاختنا
في لبنان
انه بتوجيهات حضره صاحب السمو الشيخ تميم
بن حمد ال ثاني امير البلاد المفدى امير
دوله قطر فان دوله قطر موجوده دائما لدعم
مستقبل افضل للبنان وشعبه استحوذت قطر
للطاقه اذا على كاملي حصه نوفوتيك الروسيه
وهي 20% واضافت خمسه في المئه من حصتي كل
من توتال واني بينما استقرت حصته شركتين
على 35% لكل منهما اشعر بالاعتزاز لتمكن
لبنان عبر وزاره الطاقه والمياه وهيئه
اداره القطاع البترول من اجتذاب هذا
التحالف المتين المؤلف من اهم الشركات
العالميه الرائده في مجال استخراج النفط
والغاز وهذا ان دل فعلى استمرار الثقه
بلبنان ووصف رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال في
لبنان نجيب ميقاتها لاتفاق مع شركه قطر
للطاقه بالحدث الاستثنائي هم الذي سيفتح
الطريق امام الاستثمارات العربيه
والخليجيه ذلك ان لبنان الذي يشهد انهيار
اقتصاديا هو الاسوا في تاريخه ليطلعه الى
دعم عربي ودوليا لمساعدته على الخروج من
ازمته ينقل الاتفاق مع قطر للطاقه ملفا
النفطي والغازي في لبنان الى مرحله جديده
من شانها ان تدفع مساله الاستكشاف والحفر
قدوما امر يعول عليه لبنان ماليا
واقتصاديا لاسيا ما بعد توقيع اتفاق ترسيم
الحدود البحريه الجنوبيه في اكتوبر الماضي
رغم انه لا ارقامه واضحه بعد بشان عائدات
التنقيب عن النفط والغاز يتطلع لبنان الى
ثرواته الطبيعيه لمعالجه ازمته الاقتصاديه
التي ادت الى تدهور الليره على نحو غير
مصبوق فضلا عن سد الفجوه في الميزانيه
العامه للدوله واعاده جذب الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه بيروت